Most of us have a favorite actor, and a lot
of the time it means we’re more likely to
see a movie if they’re in it.
For better or worse.
Some fans even go as far as binge-watching
their favorite performers stuff back to back
thanks to the level of access streaming services
provide.
Often, someone’s entire body of work can
be found in the one place.
But a few hours in to your marathon, you might
start to notice some habits you can’t unsee.
These are 10 Famous Actors Who Do The Same
Thing In Every Movie.
Harrison Ford, always pointing
It’s impolite to point, so maybe that’s
why Harrison Ford likes it.
The actor’s low tolerance for stupidity
has earned him a reputation as being “difficult”.
Even though most people agree that responding
to the same shallow questions day in and day
out would lend itself to boredom.
Plus, a little attitude keeps things interesting.
Ford seems to be attracted to characters with
the same outlook.
The proof is in his most iconic roles: Indiana
Jones and Han Solo.
But when fans took a closer look at the actor’s
resume another theme emerged: pointing.
Conan O’Brien even brought it up when Ford
swung by for an interview in 2013, and proved
it with a montage.
Sean Bean, always dying
Even if you don't know Sean Bean by name,
you probably recognize him as “that actor
who always dies.”
He’s also an incredibly talented performer.
But from Goldeneye to Game of Thrones, the
guy’s characters always seem destined for
death.
In fact, he’s died so many times, that fans
have even made entire montages dedicated to
it.
And with his feet planted in both television
and film, the actor has double the opportunity
to die compared to his counterparts.
While the math might not be totally sound
on that last point, the fact remains that
Bean’s characters take journeys that (almost
always) end in death.
Samuel L. Jackson, always yelling
Samuel L. Jackson does not have an indoor
voice, so don’t give him any lines he can’t
shout.
The actor has become famous for his trademark
yelling in all his movies.
While most of us need a reason to raise our
voices, his reason happens to be that he’s
Samuel L. Jackson.
Apparently the film’s genre doesn’t really
matter either, as he’s screamed his way
through kids movies, Tarantino flicks, and
even some recent Marvel fare.
His outbursts can range from joyful to antagonistic.
They’re downright intimidating, but we wouldn’t
want it any other way.
Because ultimately, all the yelling is kind
of endearing.
Michelle Rodriguez, always a badass
Hollywood has struggled with gender stereotyping
since it’s inception.
And depending on what side of the fence you’re
on, they’ve either come a long way or have
a long way to go.
There may be more ladies on screen now than
in decades past, but a common argument emerging
is that their characters are derogatory, one-dimensional,
and sometimes both.
When Michelle Rodriguez bucked trends in 2000’s
Girlfight, the actress found herself on a
tough-girl trajectory.
Looking over her 16 year career since, not
much has changed except the names of the characters.
Rodriguez is never not a badass.
Jack Nicholson, always with the eyebrows
All of the performers on this list have huge
fanbases, but none of them have been around
along as Jack Nicholson’s.
Involved with the business since the late
fifties, the actor has an incredibly diverse
resume and has been working steadily since
the beginning.
So have his eyebrows.
The actor may switch roles constantly but
those brows don’t lie.
Nicholson uses that to his advantage.
He’s taken home a handful of Oscars and
has been nominated in every decade since he
started working.
It’s worth noting that the actor shares
this honor with Michael Caine.. a man who
also has excellent eyebrows.
Coincidence?
Brad Pitt, always eating
Let’s face it, a lot of us look disgusting
when we eat, and no amount of etiquette training
is going to change that.
Even the beautiful people struggle to stay
glamorous at meal time, but Brad Pitt is a
well-documented exception.
Watch carefully and you’ll notice that the
actor eats in almost every single movie he
stars in.
All kinds of food, too; twinkies, ice cream,
steak, nachos, and lots of chips.
If this is something you noticed before we
brought it up, good for you eagle-eyes!
But if it slipped past you until now, you
won’t be able to miss it the next time it
happens.
Julia Roberts, always crying
Julia Roberts has done her fair share of tear-jerking,
heart-obliterating movies.
And has been Hollywood royalty since playing
Richard Gere’s escort in 1990’s Pretty
Woman.
Since her resume is stacked with dramatic
flare, she’s done more on-screen crying
than most.
And has won more than a couple of awards along
the way.
With a ton of box office successes under her
belt, millions of people have seen Roberts
turn on the waterworks in the name of cinema.
They seem to like it, too.
Because she shows no signs of stopping.
Tom Cruise, always running
Tom Cruise likes to run.
And while he’s not on the same level as
people who jog at 5 am during the Canadian
winter, he’s still pretty dedicated.
Just watch literally any movie he’s ever
done and you’ll see him run his heart out
at some point.
He’s run from aliens, explosions, and dust
storms.
He’s run through time and traffic.
He doesn’t stop for anything, and no obstacles
seem to be of any consequence.
The actor keeps in shape and does a lot of
his own stunt work.
Whereas the only marathons we’ve been doing
lately are of the Netflix variety.
Ryan Reynolds, always sarcastic
Some people are of the mindset that sarcasm
is the lowest form of comedy, but Ryan Reynolds
is living proof of the opposite.
The actor has a penchant for humorous roles,
and cruises through complicated dialogue with
ease.
He was drawn to the role of Deadpool, and
the fusion of his comedic timing with the
script writing turned out to be a match made
in cinematic heaven.
Reynolds’ super-sarcasm doesn’t end there
though, and is almost always central to whatever
character he plays.
But hey, if it ain’t broke, don’t fix
it.
We wouldn’t change a thing.
Nicolas Cage, always throwing tantrums
Okay let’s be real: nobody really understands
what’s going on with Nicolas Cage’s movie
choices as of late.
Sure, he may have been nominated for five
Razzies in the worst actor category, but he’s
never actually won any of them.
He does have an Oscar from 1995 though.
It seems that critics have agreed to disagree
when it comes to Cage.
But everyone acknowledges that the man throws
one hell of a tantrum.
He must know it too, because it happens in
nearly every movie he makes.
Most of our personal favorites happen during
2006’s The Wicker Man, but everyone’s
got their preference.
So what do you think of our list?
Did we miss any other actors who do the same
thing in every movie?
Tell us about them in the comments, and subscribe
to our YouTube channel for more videos like
this one.